[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous avons modifié
aujourd'hui le thème de l'émission
dimanche en politique pour évoquer
jacques chirac l'ancien président de la
république décédé jeudi à l'âge de 86
ans trois invités avec nous sur ce
plateau pour évoquer l'homme son action
politique
son héritage tout d'abord deux
chiraquiens convaincu
damien meslot mer les républicains de
belfort et ancien député du territoire
de belfort
face à lui michel raison sénateurs les
républicains de haute saône et ancien
député de ce département
et puis martial bourquin sénateur
socialiste du doubs n'oubliez pas grâce
à twitter vous pouvez commenter réagir à
cette émission grâce au hashtag dit mme
paul fc comme dimanche en politique
franche comté alors on va commencer tout
d'abord cette émission avec vous michel
raison
quand est-ce que vous avez rencontré
jacques chirac pour la première fois
comment ça s'est passé
la première fois c'était à vesoul parce
que à l'époque à autre chose les
principaux dirigeants du rpr était
balladuriens donc on était très peu
nombreux à soutenir jacques chirac et je
les ai accueillis au sabot de frotter
avec mon ami philippe legrand qui avait
rejoint tout à fait au début quand même
mais il avait rejoint et il était
président parce que depuis l'été vous
l'aviez jamais rencontrés avant mais
vous le soutenir ben déjà oui ben je
l'adorais enfin c'était évidemment que
je le soutenais et ses joues on en
parlera au cours de l'émission après une
fois qu'on l'a eue rencontré plusieurs
fois une fois que j'ai été député salle
dédiée à ce sont forcément renforcée
parce qu'on apprend à mieux connaître le
personnage mais cette rencontre en 95 6
et des souvenirs merveilleux
lorsqu'elle s'est d'autant plus
merveilleux qui va devenir président
dary oui alors il est à 14% moi je lui
avais écrit en janvier lui disant on
n'est pas trop bien mais de toute façon
vous avez mon soutien jusqu'au bout et
quand il est venu à vesoul il était à
14%
à l'époque on était loin des 50 et
qu'elle est on va voir qu'il fallait que
parce que je pense pas que ce soit la
bonne réseau mais ces sondages sont
envolés après sa visite à vesoul comme
si ça elle lui avait porté chance
damien et cela on peut dire que c'est
grâce à jacques chirac ou à cause de
jacques chirac peut-être dire on vous
opposant politique
vous aujourd'hui vous faites de la
politique et ce depuis quelques années
déjà
oui tout à fait j'ai adhéré au rpr 1979
j'ai 14 ans et demi et j'adorais chirac
et c'est pour chirac que j'ai adhéré au
rpr et j'ai toujours suivi jacques
chirac dans toutes les élections
j'ai fait sa campagne aux 80 en 88 95 30
2002 trois campagnes avant de regagner
une quand même deux enfants cadre il a
gagné qu'assayas rico de 10 à michel
c'était un peu compliqué que les
balladuriens
mais après c'était la plus belle
victoire je me souviens du soir de la
victoire c'était vraiment fantastique
est jacques chirac je lis toujours
soutenu que c'est un homme que j'adorais
la première rencontre avec lui ça date
de quand alors c'était en 1983 il était
venu dans un meeting soutenir pierre
bonnet ce qui était candidat contre jean
pierre chevènement élections municipales
à belfort alors vous vous êtes opposant
théoriquement à jacques chirac puisque
vous êtes de gauche
est ce que vous l'avez rencontré wii ou
aperçu aperçu aperçu j'étais un camp
adverse - on va pas vous savez quand des
grandes personnalités comme ça décède
on refait l'histoire parfois non on
était adversaires en même temps derrière
jacques chirac j'ai quelques flashs qui
me reviennent très fort c'était sa
visite en israël
oulaï ferme il fait fait preuve d'un
grand sang froid est ce que j'ai
apprécié de faire un esclandre par
rapport à la sécurité qui croient que
guette le faire quand même
et la deuxième chose c'est le refus de
la guerre d'irak fallait le faire parce
qu'il avait prévu ce qui se passerait
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre d'irak qui
christ mais vous l'avez vu en vrai ou
pas vous l'avez juste croisé cadre oise
et croisée il était aussi grand qu'on le
dit m 93 une certaine stature de la voie
de la prestance migrants grand et puis
c'était une personnalité votre chef de
parti et puis pas n'importe lequel
alors moi je soutenais systématiquement
le camp en face de caen face voilà
mais après quand vous avez un certain
recul une fois qu'il est président de la
république on se dit qu'est ce qu'il a
fait de bien quand par exemple il
reconnaît les crimes contre l'humanité
de l'état français devises
si c'est le premier président ça c'était
à propos de la raf du duvet leur a
laissé le 16 juillet 1995 il vient juste
d'être élu la république c'est ça en
tant qu'homme de gauche c'est ça que
vous retenez oui on quand on est on est
fier d'être français quand on entend un
prénom de la république jeu même si les
panneaux de caen dire des choses vous
avez regretté que françois mitterrand le
fasse pas plutôt bien sûr je prêche
était heureux que jacques chirac le
fasse et et quand dominique de villepin
parle à l'onu et qu'il y ait ensuite la
conférence de presse de jacques chirac
je me sens français c'est que ça c'est
donc le refus de suivre les américains
pour la guerre ont quand même s'il ira
créé visionnaire parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous imaginez ce qui s'est passé depuis
et c'était en 2003 damien meslot vous
qu'est ce que vous retenez comme action
politique
moi je retiens comme l'a dit martial
bourquin la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
la déportation des juifs c'est quand
même quelque chose d'important et c'est
une vraie inflexion dans la politique
français c'est la naissance je suis pris
en défaut le gaulliste que vous êtes
parce que quand même c'est charles de
gaulle qui a voulu à la fin de la guerre
qui est l'image d'une france unie du
goal cas de gaulle avait besoin après la
guerre d'avoir une france unie douch
assis gaulle ont pacifié donc charles de
gaulle était dans cette ligne là et
jacques chirac a considéré en 95 donc
cinquante ans après la fin de la guerre
qu'il était temps de reconnaître de
reconnaître la responsabilité de l'état
français
ça c'est habilité la culpabilité de
l'état français ça c'est important
et puis bien sûr le refus de la guerre
en irak et la fin du service militaire
obligatoire qui nous permet d'avoir une
véritable armée de métier michel raison
j'allais justement rebondir sur ce
service militaire parce que c'était un
visionnaire en politique internationale
ya le côté visionnaire par rapport au
refus de la guerre en irak
additionnée au courage de s'opposer aux
états unis ya pas beaucoup de pays
européens qui l'ont fait et donc il l'a
fait avec beaucoup de courage a zappé
visionnaire beaucoup de gens à gauche ça
a plu bon rythme oui mais
aussi les gaullistes que vous êtes aussi
est donc l'histoire du service militaire
était visionnaire au site est très
difficile comme décision ça a pas plus
mais il savait bien qu'on ne pourrait
plus dans les temps modernes avoir une
armée qui n'était pas professionnelle
notamment parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'opérations extérieures rien n'a pas
envoyé d appeler aulas l'a vu après
effet voilà c'était d'ailleurs une de
ses premières décisions et c'était
extrêmement important c'est ce que vous
retenez le plus alors on retient
beaucoup d'autres choses l'histoire de
la complicité voire la culpabilité de la
france dans la raf aussi tout sept ans
tout cet ensemble sur l'avenue - déjà il
ya unanimité taux de ce côté à la fois
visionnaire courageux et très
internationale dans ses analyses
alors ça c'est pour le côté on va dire
positif et qui vous met tous d'accord
tous les trois la fracture sociale c'est
ça qu'il fait lire en 95 est ce que vous
n'avez pas été déçus après par le fait
justement que il n'est pas fait diminuer
le chômage que cette fracture sociale il
n'est pas réussi ni ce avant lui ni ce
après lui nos paru si justement à la
réduire si vous voulez bien évidemment
nous aurions préféré que en la matière
on est les meilleurs résultats mais il
faut pas oublier que jacques chirac à ce
moment là n'a que deux ans puisque 97
une décision malencontreuse devant ce
qui fait que
lionel jospin arrive arrive au pouvoir
et donc on ne peut pas mettre en place
la politique consultation parce que s'il
y avait plus de temps la fracture se je
pense que gérard s'est trouvé dans une
situation dégradée d'ailleurs quand
jacques chirac alain juppé sont arrivés
là président l'autre premier ministre
s'y soit perçu que la situation laissée
par le gouvernement balladur était bien
moins bonne que ce à quoi on s'attendait
et donc il a fallu prendre une série de
mesures fiscales difficiles puisqu'il a
fallu augmenter les impôts pour
redresser les comptes de la france
et après ça crée une agitation sociale
qui mène à la dissolution et qui ne
permettent pas d'appliquer le programme
michel raison la fracture sociale bon
j'ai un témoignage de jacques chirac sur
ce sujet parce que lorsqu'il a pu était
président j'allais le voir il était tout
près de l'assemblée nationale son bureau
rue de lille au croisement du boulevard
saint-germain donc à 100 mètres de
l'assemblée nationale j'ai eu des
discussions avec lui il était déjà un
peu affaibli mais ont discuté tout à
fait normalement avec lui et un moment
donné je les ai sentis un peu comme
déprimée parce que justement il aurait
voulu pouvoir y arriver plus mais c'est
un sujet extrêmement difficile puisque
pour le moment dans aucun pays on a
réussi à mieux rééquilibrer les plus
faibles et plus forts diminuer les
écarts même si en france c'était la
meilleure l'accès principal à 10 et un
de ses principaux regrets alors la
fracture sociale
quel regard que vous portez vous
l'opposant de gauche à la fois dans la
campagne il a l'intuition que cette
fracture sociale grandit on est sur un
renforcement très importante de la
mondialisation et on commence à déceler
les inégalités qui grandissent avec la
mondialisation
en même temps ils mènent des politiques
d'austérité assez forte et c'est là
qu'on est des opposants c'est là qu'il
ya des manifestations très importants
notamment les retraites en 80 que le
retrait du cpe
voilà voilà le contrat première embauche
voile alors là c'est voilà où je suis
dans l'opposition je participe à ces
manifestations et
cette dissolution imprévisible c'est là
que l'animal politique au sens
aristotélicien du terme
quel chirac fait un coup de poker qui
perd ils se parlent toujours de son
flair mais leïla et nana pas là il y en
a pas hyper parce que justement il est
corrèze c'est une personne qui a des
liens extrêmement étroit avec la
population il sent que les politiques
qui se met en place sont pas les
politiques qu'il faut pour la france
il sent aussi que le modèle français est
en cause mais en même temps les
politiques qui met en place sont des
politiques vraiment osterrieth r michel
raison la dissolution et alors par
contre c'est les politiques autoritaires
elles ont été beaucoup plus après la
pause la réforme des retraites on le
voit bien aujourd'hui si seulement il
avait pu mettre en place cette réforme
dès ce moment là on n'aurait pas besoin
d'en faire autant aujourd'hui
et si mitterrand n'était pas passer d'un
seul coup de 62 65 à 60 et qui soit
passé à 63 n'en parlerai même pas
aujourd'hui c'est une parenthèse les
discours c'est peut-être et dieu sait si
j'ai de l'amitié et l'émotion que j'ai
eues en apprenant son décès hier dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
la dissolution je remets pas en cause à
joindre tous les élus ont des moments
difficiles peuvent pas gagner chaque
fois ils peuvent se tromper
la seule question que j'ai en tant que
gaulliste c'est et il a dû s'imposer
aussi est-ce qu'il fallait qu'il
démissionne ou pas donc je suppose que
là il était désavoué
on est d'accord oui s'il était vraiment
gaulliste il aurait dû partir comme le
général c'est le sentiment que j'ai
alors peut-être qu'il s'est dit que ça
serait peut-être encore plus compliquée
pour le pays
j'espère que c'est cette thèse là qui
l'a poussé à rester et j'espère que
c'est pas la thèse de garder le pouvoir
à tout prix
damien ressiot vous pensez qu'ils
auraient pu dû démissionner non je pense
pas qu'il aurait dû démissionner je
pense qu'il n'aurait pas de vaccin -
gaullisme voilà que je pense que dans l
erreur l'erreur non jeu michel raison et
pour gaulliste sinon plus que moi on a
pas qu'au cours de gaullisme simplement
moi je pense que l'erreur de jacques
chirac était de ne pas dissoudre au
lendemain de son élection en 95 pour
avoir une majorité qui soit à sa main
parce que là on avait laissé des
divisions entre balladuriens
et chiraquiens qui restait juste
expliqué pour les jeunes générations qui
à l'époque s'était pas automatique il
n'y avait pas une élection
présidentielle suivie de légistes âge
mais qui avait en fait les deux mandats
qui se chevauchent ali ses chevauchées
et sanogo adecco jacques chirac aurait
dû dissoudre des 95 pour avoir 5 ans il
s'est engagé à pas le faire il a voulu
respecter sa parole c'est cela qui à mon
avis entraîner des difficultés futures
la logique politique aurait voulu qui
dissolvent à l'assemblée au lendemain de
son élection pour avoir 5 ans pour mener
sa politique je pense c'est elle à
l'erreur il avait dit il avait dans ce
cadre un prédécesseurs illustres qui
avait montré que le pouvoir n'est jamais
totalement perdu et il subit c'était
françois mitterrand bien sûr la
cohabitation est ce que téhéran a été
réélu malgré la cohabitation absolument
eh bien peut-être avec l'accord
d'association grâce à la cohabitation
rac avait été un excellent premier
minutes et est hélas il refait le même
la même chose qu'a fait françois
mitterrand
voilà il ya loin de los surtout pas il
il était il était je pense que il ya
aussi un autre point qu'on n'a pas
abordé
je lui reconnais aussi une
intransigeance face au front national
qui est totale il a été parfois approché
par des membres du front national pour
essayer d'unir une partie de la droite
avec et jacques chirac a toujours été
d'une grande clarté là dessus c'est ce
qui m'a amené à voter pour lui lorsqu'il
sert tout fait en face de jean marie le
pen parce qu'à un moment donné il ya des
choses en démocratie qu'on n'accepte pas
et là dessus il a été exemple même s'il
avait 10 ans donnait il avait le bruit
et l'odeur à bruno gehrig ses terres et
que j'ai profondément regretté j'étais
scandalisé par cela mais en même temps
lorsqu'il s'agissait de faire des choix
politiques
il les a toujours fait contre le
fondation le bruit et l'odeur vous avez
réagi comment moi je pense que c'était
sorti de son contexte jacques charge et
aurélie rhin jacques chirac était tout
sauf arras
c'est xénophobe toute sa carrière
politique toute sa politique étrangère
le montrent il a toujours voulu dire le
pays il a eu je suis d'accord avec
martial mort qu'à une intransigeance
totale avec le front national
ç'a toujours été là line souvenez vous
des régionales ici on s'en souvient bien
où notre président de région
jean-françois humbert préfère
démissionner plutôt que d'être élue avec
les voix du front national
et je veux dire ces réseaux cela montre
bien que jacques chirac n'était pas si
michel raison
votre réaction quand vous avez vous
entendu le bruit et l'odeur vous avez
réagi comment alors déjà ja sybille pas
du tout ça comme ça va paraître
anarchiste donc que ce soit une
maladresse verbale à la limite mais vous
savez quand le président m'a kron a osé
dire il était encore pas président et
ministre que des salariés étaient des
illettrés ça m'a beaucoup plus choqué
parce que moi je côtoie les salariés
toute la journée et je connais des
salariés des usines de la chaîne qui
quand ils reviennent le soir chez eux
écrivent des poèmes
le lendemain vont à la chorale vont
regarder un film de haut niveau c'est ça
aussi les salariés et ça ça m'a beaucoup
plus mais ça m'a vraiment marqué alors
après est-ce que vous avez été choqué
quand jacques chirac a été condamné deux
ans avec sursis pour les emplois fictifs
à la mairie de paris en fait c'était une
gigantesque pompe à finances du rpr est
ce que ça vous a embêté alors ça m'a
chagriné parce que j'aimais beaucoup
s'agira l'analyse est simple
à l'époque les partis politiques
n'étaient pas financés par les fonds
d'état le parti socialiste a eu la
sphère urbain je n'ai pas voulu non plus
il avait monté une grosse machine de
guerre pour pouvoir récupérer de
l'argent êtes en train de dire que tout
le monde faisait ça quoi non mais il n'y
avait pas de financement de parti
politique et donc je ne dis pas que
c'était bien je ne dis pas que c'était
autorisé mais il employait dans les
mairies
oui mais quand même damien les sociétés
à grande échelle pour vous aurez à se
faire peur on était organisée c'est tout
je veux 17e muets hormis les quelques
jeux organisés que les autres mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il n'y avait
pas de financement on savait que les
campagnes électorales coûtait de
l'argent et on ne les finance est pas de
tout le monde savait que ça se passe
et par des fausses factures ou des
emplois fictifs à l'époque tout le monde
l'accepté
le monde a changé il ya des lois sur le
financement je suis très favorable à ses
doigts et maintenant ça ne se passait
plus comme ça à l'époque tout le monde
le faisait à gauche quand même on disait
chirac fripouille y'avait supermenteur
chez manuel est à peine plus alors non
je pense que le problème de la france
par rapport notamment aux pays
scandinaves
c'est d'avoir pris un retard terrible
sur le financement des partis politiques
et des campagnes électorales et ce qui a
amené des dérives comme celles là
c'était peut-être aussi le la dichotomie
les lois allemandes la population
absolument les électeurs et citoyens par
rapport au politique c'est pour cela que
on appris on a trop tardé
alors quand on savait que d'autres pays
européens depuis longtemps et est et
ensuite il y avait des circuits de
financement complètement occulte qui ont
été condamnés après par la suite mais
alors que vous oui est ce que vous
pensez damien meslot que ce genre
d'affaires justement ça peut éloigner le
citoyen je vais vous savez où il allait
payer
peut-être mais dans les pays scandinaves
que vous citez les partis populistes
faut aussi beaucoup de voix donc je
pense que ce qui éloigne la population
et les citoyens de la politique c'est
aussi l'évolution de nos sociétés
c'est aussi un certain nombre d'effets
comme la mondialisation qui fait que les
citoyens
on a de plus en plus de normes dans
notre pays on a de plus en plus noble et
peut-être que les politiques vous avez
moins en moins de moyens voilà c'est ça
je pense que la vie fait l'évolution de
la politique fait que les citoyens ont
l'impression que les élus ps de moins en
moins sur les évolutions de la société
du monde et c'est ça qui éloigne a pas
eu d'enrichissement personnel en plus
rejeter pour faire fonctionner le parti
mais il n'avait pas besoin non plus
d'avoir d'argent puisqu'il avait
beaucoup de mandats qu'ils avaient des
logements de fonctions mentales vigor on
en a connu d'autres qu'avaient les mêmes
choses à droite comme à gauche qui tire
à kia et sarkozyste
et qu'est ce que vous avez pensé jour où
nicolas sarkozy a traité jacques chirac
de roi fainéant
je pense que c'était excessif c'est pas
la meilleure phrase que je retiendrai de
nicolas sarkozy moi comme ou comme
beaucoup d'autres comme christian
jacob comme françois baroin on a
toujours soutenu jacques chirac en
nature était proche et après on a
soutenu nicolas sarkozy
je sais que bernadette chirac par
exemple a fait de même donc vous voyez
je ne suis pas le seul
on va justement là vous entendez la
perche pour parler justement de
l'héritage qui selon vous va commencer
par vous damien meslot justement peut
incarner cet héritage chiraquien vous
venez d'en citer de la déjà aulas
christian jacob président du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale françois baroin
qui est président de l'association des
maires de france c'est eux
moi je crois que l'héritage de jacques
chirac il appartient maintenant au pays
il appartient à l'ensemble de la nation
il appartient à tous les français ce que
ce que jacques chirac a fait il l'a fait
pour l'ensemble des français qui l'adoré
parce que jacques chirac ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que sa première
qualité c'était qu'il aimait les
français il aimait la france mais il
émet des français par dessus tout vous
savez quand tu eu la coupe du monde de
foot on a dit je ce père aime le foot et
chirac m
les footballeurs je veux dire chirac
même si c'est ce n'est pas dire non oui
sous les pas de renom mais il était
tellement sympa tout le monde trouvait
chirac beaucoup plus à l'aise avec les
footballeurs que le pauvre lionel jospin
est y en a un qui a ce charisme l'acquis
à se dire ce leadership mais bon c'est à
moi de distribuer je dire les
certificats d'héritiers ou de houe de
chiraquisme mais je crois que l'héritage
de chirac hirsch écoutait martial
bourquin
tout à l'heure il va bien au delà du
mouvement gaulliste et des républicains
c'est peut-être là qu'on avait plus de
chiraquiens mais ça va bien au delà
comme l'héritage de de gaulle au bout
d'un moment à dépasser très largement
même le parti communiste où la france a
soumises dès fois se déclare gaulliste
donc ce que j'espère c'est que dans
quelques années tout bon se déclarera
chiraquien qui l'a fait le président de
la république pierre jacques chirac
rentrer dans l'histoire c'est vraiment
une des plus belles phrases qu'il ait pu
prononcer comme de gaulle fait partie de
l'histoire
ce discours là vous a plu j'ai trouvé
qu'il avait été comme d'habitude un peu
long avec quelques répétitions mais qui
il a eu quelques très belles phrases
quand même j'espère que c'est pas de la
récupération politique comme chirac est
très aimée parce qu'en même temps on en
profite un petit peu mais d'autres
ferais pareil il est le métier il avait
lui puisque en effet on distribue pas
d'accès site ou de diplômes à celui-ci
ou celui-là quand j'allais le voir
jacques chirac rue de lille j'ai
souhaité essayer d'engager la
conversation par rapport à son
successeur nicolas sarkozy mme ce cas
pas d'héritage c'est plutôt des succès
après y'a des successeurs il m'a répondu
sobrement il me dit je me suis juré de
ne jamais rien dire ni sur mon
prédécesseur ni son mon successeur et la
conversation sur ce sujet étaient
terminées vous alors l'héritier c'est
peut être ça peut être
christian jacob qui brigue actuellement
elle a peur des ria pas d'invité y aura
des successeurs on a un peu de mal
d'ailleurs en ce moment à droite comme à
gauche a trouvé la personnalité qui
pourrait l'emporter aux élections pour
qu'il puisse y avoir une alternance
crédible dans le pays c'est ça qu'on
cherche à nous lasser des gens qui ont
du charisme que je sais pas si on en
manque peut-être qu'il n'a pas encore
levé le doigt on en a forcément moi j'en
connais on connaît des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui ont des niveaux excellente
et à et s'adresse à martial bourquin
puisqu'ils sont tous les deux ou au
sénat ah oui mais on connaît aussi bien
à gauche qu'à droite d'ailleurs
il ya des gens qui sont capables de
relever le défi mais vous savez pour
être candidat à la présidence de
république et c'est un sacrifice aussi
alors soit on a beaucoup d'ego et on ne
pense qu'à ça et on s'occupe pas du
sacrifice soit on a des personnes
citons par exemple françois baroin
je suis dit que c'est quelque part son
fils et spiritueux le ver est
parfaitement les fausses mais faut pas
perdu son père et que jacques chirac a
s'est occupé de moi je suis très ami
avec françois baroin j'ai déjà échangé
sur ce sujet là avec lui jusqu'à il ya
encore quelques mois il se sentait pas
forcément prêts si vous êtes président
de la république c'est un sacrifice
énorme
vous avez plus de lui il ya quand même
ça doit pas être si dramatique que ça
faisait quand même beaucoup de candidats
qui veulent être président de la
république ou wii battu chaque élection
veut certes un certain niveau à voir il
faut être prêt à tout sacrifier à une
vraie h ma vie et c'est vrai que
françois baroin parce qu'on a tous pensé
à lui il décide pour le moment il nous
dit que je vais d'abord m'occuper des
municipales à 3 donc aide l'association
des bains de l'association de verbes
soeur sa mère riche trahi sa famille et
l'association des maires de france c'est
quand même un bon j'allais dire lobby
quand on veut devenir président de la
république non c'est un bon réseau mais
pour le moment il faut attendre sa
décision
martial bourquin comprendrez que ce mes
collègues les problèmes de leadership
des républicains enfin je ne m'en mêle
pas à à gauche et au parti socialiste
avait le même on a sauvé les amendes
travail à gauche et au parti socialiste
est dans l'ensemble de la gauche et des
écologistes à régler simplement il ya
quelques idées quand même parce que là
on entend beaucoup de choses qui
viennent un peu de partout
quand je pense que on va avoir une loi
de finances dans peu de temps
je regarde qu'on va retirer je crois que
tu es 3 milliards pour les apl que on a
pris dans la poche des retraités pour
donner l'aja sort qui l'avait faire un
peu de récupération pauline ombre non
non non je ne dis qu'aucun président de
la république n'avait tenté cela je dis
parce que vous savez quand on regarde
les bilans serait qu'on peut dire des
bilans et tout cela on tourne dans une
situation là où aucun par françois
mitterrand n'en parle pas jacques celle
là aussi on est très loin de jacques
chirac
on est on est ce que j'ai dit car il n'a
pas fait tout simplement mais il a fait
d'autres choses
appâté chose pareille vous rend compte
supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune et
prend dans la peau prendre dans la poche
des retraités pour donner aux milliards
r ça perd cela vous êtes en train donc
personnes-là d'effectuer une alliance
avec eux les noms trop directe pas du
tout simplement sur un constat
dernièrement je pense que on va aux
vacances de l'émission là il restait
moins de deux minutes contrairement
emmanuel macron jacques chirac était
très proche des faibles il était très je
dire tout en ayant épousé une
aristocrate comme il était rappelé était
très proche des gens qui étaient dans la
difficulté qu'ils étaient dans des
situations de handicap et il était il
était très ils étaient prêts à donner
beaucoup à ces gens là et ils étaient
beaucoup plus rude avec les forts et
j'ai l'impression qu'ils manuel macron
c'est absolument linverse est là mais le
mot de la fin pour voir jusqu'à donner
la preuve de son humanité tout à l'heure
par rapport à ses regrets d'après 2017
mais si on regarde même son deuxième
mandat la loi de 2005 sur le handicap
on avait un retard considérable en
france sur le handicap
mais il ya une loi mais il ya eu des
moyens avec il a mis en place le grand
plan cancer et quand on en parlait avec
lui ça le saisissent c'est qui a eu des
moyens demi avec il a fait un plan sur
la sécurité routière
parce que sous jospin ça c'est du
concret monsieur gayssot en fait que de
répéter qu'il allait réduire le nombre
de tués sur la route on n'a pas réduit 1
et lui il a vraiment mis pris le
problème à bras le corps j'ai quand même
regardé évidemment comme j'ai travaillé
sur ce sujet là commence avait été fait
qu'une synergie entre tous les acteurs y
compris avec les écoles et l'on a je
l'appelle qu'en fait mille merci
messieurs
en fait vous êtes en train de dire que
nicolas sarkozy pour qui donc vous êtes
vous avez travaillé aussi puisque vous
avez août est aussi été pro président de
la république
quand nicolas sarkozy dit roi fainéant
ce n'est pas tout à fait annoncer ça
donne je voulais dire voilà merci
messieurs d'avoir participé à cette
émission
merci de votre attention et bon dimanche
après midi à tous au revoir
[Musique]